[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 j'espère que le weekend a été bon
installez-vous confortablement on
démarre la semaine ensemble avec de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici le sommaire de ce
lundi 17 avril
Emmanuel Macron doit prendre la parole
ce soir à 20h une allocution aux
Français pour tourner la page de la
réforme des retraites après la
promulgation de la loi samedi que
faut-il attendre de ce discours alors
que deux nouvelles journées de grève
sont annoncées les 20 et 28 avril nous
avons posé la question à un député de la
majorité et à un député de l'opposition
la face cachée de la politique en
Île-de-France est-ce que promet de
révéler Babette de Rosières dans son
livre qui paraîtra le 27 avril prochain
clientélisme méthode de gestion promesse
non tenue la concert régionale et chef
de cuisine yvinoise dévoile les
coulisses du pouvoir et notamment ses
relations tumultueuses avec la
présidente de l'île de France Valérie
Pécresse Babette de Rosières et notre
invité enfin comme tous les lundis les
résultats sportifs du week-end nous
ferons le point également sur les
saisons en cours de deux de nos clubs du
territoire le plaisir Rugby Club
s'apprête à disputer les phases finales
de fédéral 2 après une troisième place
obtenue en championnat et puis les
couillards de Montigny-le-Bretonneux eux
ont bien démarré l'année en division une
de baseball
et ce sera tout à l'heure dans la partie
sport avec vous Michael el midoro
bonsoir bonsoir de la rédaction de tv78
avec je le disais aussi le point sur les
résultats du week-end on va parler de
quoi ce soir on va parler football et de
la victoire de Versailles après 4 matchs
sans victoire les Versailles et se sont
imposés face à Villefranche Beaujolais
enfin j'ai envie de dire Grégory et il y
a également eu la vie la défaite de
Poissy dans le championnat de National 2
on parlera également de Arthur lorimi
qui a fait une belle performance en
karting et enfin de la victoire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce sera handball
présentation également dans le 7 8 de la
deuxième édition du Trophée mixte du CFA
de la Chambre des Métiers et de
l'Artisanat d'Île-de-France 92 apprentis
vont se retrouver ce jeudi au Centre
national du rugby à Marcoussis pour un
tournoi de rugby à 5 et parmi les
participants des apprentis et du CFA de
Versailles bonsoir Mathieu Berrier vous
êtes leur entraîneur et également chef
de travaux CFA2 Versailles j - 3 avant
l'événement est-ce que tout est prêt
est-ce que vous êtes prêt pour ce
tournoi tout est prêt tout est prêt les
jeunes sont motivés ils sont prêts en
découdre mais c'est du toucher donc
c'est pas très violent et ils sont là
pour s'amuser
et concrètement c'est quoi le rugby
toucher alors toucher c'est toucher
demain entre les épaules et on va dire
la taille pas de placage et c'est mixte
fille et garçon on aura l'occasion d'en
parler un peu plus tout à l'heure il y
aura un jeune du CFA adversaire qui sera
dans l'équipe qui sera à vos côtés tout
à l'heure pour parler de cet événement
il y a également à vos côtés le colonel
Nicolas Fouilloux bonsoir vous êtes vous
le conseiller communication du général
Christophe Abad qui est le gouverneur
militaire de Paris on va parler avec
vous tout à l'heure de cet événement
avec nos blessés qui est organisé par
l'état-major de zone de défense de Paris
ça se déroule ce jeudi dans les jardins
du domaine national de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye en quelques mots
on aura aussi l'occasion d'en dire un
peu plus tout à l'heure mais c'est quoi
avec nos blessés alors c'est une journée
de solidarité pour l'ensemble des
blessés Ess entiellement de l'armée de
terre mais aussi du service de santé des
armées donc l'objectif c'est de leur
témoigner notre solidarité au travers
d'un événement sportif qui est ouvert à
tous et qui est gratuit donc tous âges
tout le monde est bienvenu à
Saint-Germain ce jeudi on dit un peu
plus tout à l'heure bonsoir Céline
Charles de la rédaction de TV 78 dans un
instant avec vous ce qu'il faut retenir
de l'actualité du jour dans les Yvelines
et ce sera juste après les prévisions
météo de demain
une belle journée normalement au
programme de ce mardi éclairci ou grand
soleil dans la matinée selon où vous
vous trouvez dans les Yvelines il faudra
compter 8 degrés dans les secteurs de
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et où dans
dans l'après-midi le ciel se voilera se
voilera par endroits mais ça devrait
rester agréable côté température compter
14 degrés Versailles et ou dans 15
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Rambouillet
et demain c'est la saint parfait on fait
le point à présent sur l'actualité du
jour dans les Yvelines
et ces informations Céline ont les
débute avec cette prise de parole ce
soir du président de la République ce
sera à 20h tout à fait une prise de
parole bien sûr attendu c'est la
première depuis la validation de
l'essentiel de la réforme des retraites
vendredi 14 avril par le Conseil
constitutionnel et là promulgation
Express samedi 15 par le président
Emmanuel Macron une réforme comme vous
le savez très contestée en témoigne les
trois mois de crise politique et sociale
que la France a connu alors membres de
cette prise de parole s'il n'y aura de
toute évidence pas de retour en arrière
concernant la réforme le président devra
tout de même faire preuve d'empathie
selon Bruno millième député des Yvelines
écoutez je pense que le président aura
un discours volontariste parce qu'il est
comme ça parce qu'il a toujours été
comme ça il a toujours eu cette envie et
ce besoin de réformer il va falloir
qu'il mette de l'empathie dans dans ces
paroles aussi
qui montre français qu'il a bien compris
la colère qui s'est exprimée donc voilà
il faut il faut de l'empathie bien
expliquer aux Français tracer tracer
effectivement le chemin et le chemin
commun c'est à dire qu'il faut vraiment
reprendre nos modèles cette chance là on
n'a jamais rompu le dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales il faut
reprendre le chemin du dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales mais les mots
du chef de l'État ne suffiront peut-être
pas apaiser les tensions pour tout le
monde pour William Martinez député des
Yvelines la seule solution c'est le
retrait de la loi on l'écoute celui qui
a les clés pour résoudre toujours la
grave crise démocratique et sociale dans
laquelle on est c'est le président de la
République même après la validation par
le Conseil constitutionnel du projet de
loi qui est une validation du pur point
de vue juridique le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas dit si cette loi
est bonne ou mauvaise il a surtout pas
dit si on avait encore le droit ou pas
de manifester contre cette contre cette
loi le l'opposition à la réforme des
retraites elle est toujours là donc une
fois qu'on a passé cette séquence il
reste la possibilité pour le président
de la République de dire que même après
la validation du Conseil constitutionnel
il retire ce projet de loi et moi je
suis encore convaincu que c'est la
solution la plus sage
un appel des rassemblements devant
toutes les mairies de France a
d'ailleurs été lancée par l'association
attaque à 20h au moment de l'allocution
l'association veuillez organiser des
concerts de casseroles autre information
que l'on a pris cet après-midi le juge
des référés du tribunal administratif de
Versailles en jouant l'état de prendre
en urgence 12 mesures pour préserver la
sécurité les droits fondamentaux des
personnes détenues au centre
pénitentiaire de Bois-d'Arcy tout à fait
Grégory cette décision fait suite à un
référé liberté déposé début avril par
plusieurs organisations d'avocats et par
l'Observatoire international des prisons
tous dénonçaient les conditions de
détention jugées dangereuse et indignes
au sein du Centre Pénitentiaire 23
mesures étaient demandées dans
lesquelles on retrouvait par exemple des
douches salutes ou encore de l'eau
chaude la décision a été rendue cet
après-midi après une audience le 12
avril dernier le juge des référés du
tribunal à je cite estimez qu'une
atteinte gravée manifeste aux libertés
fondamentales des personnes détenues
étaient établies à titre d'exemple taux
d'occupation du centre pénitentiaire
atteignait les 152,5%
au 1er mars 2023 le juge a surtout en
juin au ministre de la Justice et au
préfet des Yvelines de prendre 12
mesures au plus tard dans un délai de 10
jours parmi elles contrôler la sécurité
des risques incendie et d'hygiène
alimentaire et sanitaires autre
information et autres centres
pénitentiaire futur centre pénitentiaire
même puisque la ville de Magnanville a
été retenue pour la construction d'une
maison d'arrêt futur maison d'arrêt
plusieurs mois que le projet de
construction d'un centre pénitentiaire à
Magnanville faisait parler de lui
vendredi dernier le comité de pilotage
s'est réuni à la préfecture des Yvelines
à Versailles et à confirmé son intention
d'implanter la maison d'arrêt de 700
places sur le site de Magnanville un
projet largement contesté par les
habitants et les élus locaux depuis le
début des manifestations sont organisées
contre le projet une nouvelle
mobilisation c'est d'ailleurs tenu dans
la commune ce dimanche 16 avril à
l'initiative de l'association tous
mobilisés contre le projet de centre
pénitentiaire à Magnanville le maire de
la ville Michel Lebouc a quant à lui
annoncé à nos confrères du Parisien son
intention d'attaquer en justice on
l'attendait avec impatience plusieurs
reports mais le nano-satellite inspire 7
seven conçu par le l'Atmos laboratoire
atmosphère observation spatiale de
l'université Versailles 50 ans divine
enfin rejoint l'espace c'était samedi
dernier oui après six reports dont le
dernier date de vendredi dernier
justement le lancement d'une nano
satellite a pu enfin s'effectuer de la
base de vanderburg en Californie ce
samedi une belle réussite pour le Latmos
inspire ça de Seven a ensuite été mise
en orbite à plus de 500 km de la Terre
1h05 après son départ de la fusée Falcon
nine de Space X il a retrouvé le premier
nano satellite u vs cussat déjà en
orbite autour de la Terre et on le
rappelle ce nouveau nano-satellite va
observer le Soleil et la Terre pour
affiner notre connaissance du changement
climatique ministériel du côté de Poissy
au lycée des métiers Adrienne Bolland
c'est la ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle Caroline Carole
Grandjean pardon qui est venu sur place
au lycée à Poissy est un établissement
de 730 élèves qui dispensent différentes
formations des métiers d'art au service
à la personne comme vous pouvez le voir
sur les
[Musique]
et on en parlait en début d'émission
c'est ce jeudi à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
l'opération avec nos blessés se
déroulent de 10 heures à 17h dans les
jardins du domaine national de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye une grande journée
de solidarité pour les blessés
militaires organisés par l'état-major de
zone de défense de Paris on en parle je
disais avec le colonel Nicolas Fouilloux
qui est avec nous en plateau conseiller
communication du général Christophe Abad
gouverneur militaire de Paris et vous le
disiez tout à l'heure vous commenciez à
en parler l'objectif de la journée c'est
de sensibiliser le le grand public à la
question des blessés de guerre les
blessés militaires tout à fait alors
effectivement c'est une journée qui se
fait annuellement dans les armées et le
but c'est d'y associer bien sûr la
population parce que les armées sont le
reflet de notre société nous avons tous
peut-être des amis ou de la famille
militaire donc l'objectif c'est de
sensibiliser le plus grand nombre l'an
dernier alors il y a un compteur
kilométrique c'est à dire on peut courir
faire du vélo ou faire du rameur l'an
dernier on avait fait 5000 km à
Saint-Germain on espère faire cette
année l'objectif c'est de battre ses
5000 pièces on va les battre puisque il
y a déjà entre 700 et 800 élèves élèves
pardon qui vont qui vont participer donc
on remercie bien sûr la mairie de
Saint-Germain parce que ça se fait en
accord avec l'Amérique Saint-Germain le
monsieur PERICARD qui est qui va
accueillir le gouverneur de Paris jeudi
matin et qui vont lancer cette journée à
10h donc un opéricart maire de
Saint-Germain
de rendre hommage à ses blessés mais il
faut leur témoigner notre solidarité
parce qu'effectivement les gens les
soldats quand ils sont blessés on peut
on peut avoir tendance peut-être à les
oublier contrairement aux gens qu'on
voit tous les jours et c'est vraiment
très important de leur témoigner cette
solidarité au travers d'événements comme
ça qui se font partout en France dans
tous les régiments de France il y a une
journée qui est dédiée à la solidarité
avec les blessés on parle de 200 à 300
français qui sont blessés sur les
théâtres d'opérations chaque année alors
chaque année
j'ai pas un
sur sur des durées très longues quel est
le parcours justement d'un militaire
blessé c'est un parcours qui est assez
long finalement alors effectivement
comme vous le dites ça dépend de la
blessure une blessure physique en
fonction de la gravité le soldat peut se
remettre de ses blessures plus ou moins
rapidement il y a des traitements très
lourds vous savez qu'on a des gens qui
parfois doivent subir des amputations de
la rééducation fonctionnelle très longue
qui peut aller jusqu'à plusieurs années
aux Invalides on a l'Institution
nationale des Invalides qui s'occupent
justement de la rééducation de ces
soldats ça peut aller jusqu'à plus de 10
ans parfois avec des traitements lourds
et de la des traitements orthopédiques
des prothèses donc on a besoin de
financer tout ça et il faut faire
connaître
cette cote de blessés qu'il faut
accompagner pas uniquement
symboliquement mais aussi avec des
mécènes qui nous aident à financer ces
dispositifs donc événements avec nos
blessés pour justement les soutenir vous
le disiez ça s'adresse à tout le monde
l'idée c'est de convier le plus grand
nombre autour de cette question oui
alors il y a une bonne communication qui
a été faite au niveau de la municipalité
mais c'est pas réservé aux
saint-germainois comme on dit c'est
aussi tous les habitants des Yvelines
les versaillers les gens qui viennent
des environs ils peuvent converger jeudi
matin le rendez-vous c'est 10h le
lancement de on va dire de la journée
10h à 17h donc il y en a pour tous les
goûts pour tous les âges une fois encore
c'est gratuit donc c'est j'allais dire
on vient bénévolement faire du sport
c'est de la rubrique sport mais et donc
il y a plusieurs écoles qui ont prévu de
faire des établissements scolaires
également qui ont prévu de faire la
séquence de sport de la journée à cette
occasion pour sensibiliser le plus jeune
donc on peut venir à 10h pas
d'inscription au préalable on peut venir
directement sur place libre on se
présente et on choisit on va dire son
activité tout au long de la journée donc
on peut courir faire du vélo de la
marche tout l'important c'est de battre
ces 5000 km
l'important déjà c'est d'être présent
parce que c'est un témoignage de une
fois encore de solidarité de de
compassion vis-à-vis des gens qui
souffrent et ils y sont très sensibles
en tenue de sport c'est mieux oui c'est
mieux c'est mieux après en fonction de
il y a aussi du vélo d'appartement on
peut le faire j'allais dire on peut
avoir des des passants qui se promènent
et qui peuvent faire une demi-heure de
vélo d'appartement s'il le souhaite
est-ce que vous voulez passer un dernier
message peut-être à nos téléspectateurs
dernière question et bah qui regarde
l'émission bah leur les enjoindre
toujours à participer à ces à ces causes
solidaires le gouverneur militaire de
Paris organise tous les ans des
activités caritatives au profit des
blessés et des familles endeuillées ce
n'est pas que réservé aux militaires ou
à leur famille c'est c'est bien une
cause nationale je pense donc j'habite
le plus grand nombre à être présent j'y
serai moi-même jeudi matin donc
rendez-vous jeudi matin et normalement
il fera beau il fera beau ce sera
Saint-Germain-en-Laye et naturel le 24
juin à Paris aussi alors effectivement
la journée nationale on va dire
parisienne ce sera le 24 juin mais ceux
qui viennent jeudi peuvent revenir le 24
juin ils seront à nouveau les bienvenus
donc l'opération avec nos blessés on le
rappelle donc ce jeudi dans les jardins
du domaine national de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye les horaires de
10h à 17h merci colonel Nicolas
Fouilloux d'être venu en parler en
plateau conseiller communication du
général Christophe Abad d'un gouverneur
militaire de Paris on va ouvrir une page
sport à présent dans le 7 8
[Musique]
dans un instant de nouveaux invités avec
vous Michael et le midoro mais on va
prendre tout de suite la direction de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine la ville a
accueilli ce week-end la Coupe de France
de volley-ball dans un final Ford au
niveau de jours de compétition qui ont
réuni les meilleurs équipes fédérales
devant des centaines de spectateurs au
gymnase Pierre à Bérégovoy retour sur ce
rendez-vous avec Gabriel Gontier et
Mathilde de Franco
l'ambiance était bouillante ce weekend
au gymnase Pierre Bérégovoy de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine l'équipe élite
du Conflans Andrésy jouit volley-ball
accueillait un final Faure une finale à
4 en français en Coupe de France
fédérale un rendez-vous qui a attiré des
centaines de spectateurs l'ambiance
était superbe donc effectivement je
pense que ça a galvanisé les joueurs à
partir de là
l'adversaire était de qualité mais
effectivement ça a sans doute fait la
différence ouais il y avait une très
très bonne ambiance dans les tribunes
très bon enfant voilà on encouragé notre
équipe évidemment mais l'autre équipe a
bien joué également un grand plaisir de
voir un grand bon match comme ça à
domicile après un match d'une rare
intensité l'équipe coaché par Philippe
montaudoin a remporté la demi-finale le
samedi les joueurs n'ont rien lâché
jusqu'au bout on est super content et en
plus après tel match une telle intensité
on va chercher le tie-break à deux
points d'écart ça a été coupé pendant
enfin un super spectacle qui a eu du
monde j'aurais été le plus malheureux
des hommes si on avait paumé mais en
plus on a gagné avec une belle ambiance
des partenaires des élus qui étaient là
c'est voilà c'est c'est chouette une
ambiance de fou à Conflans c'est
vraiment bien et ça nous porte quand
même pour pouvoir aller chercher des
victoires comme celle-là ou c'est très
dur de jouer contre une belle équipe
d'allure le lendemain dimanche 16 avril
le club de volley-ball Conflans Andrésy
jouit à une nouvelle fois brillée mené
2-0 par Caudry l'équipe a réalisé une
remontada en s'imposant 3-2 objectif il
remporte la Coupe de France fédérale
donc Michael et midoro toujours en
plateau des invités qui nous ont
également rejoint il y a Thierry Lamandé
président du plaisir Rugby Club bonsoir
bonsoir à vous Bastien cheval également
de l'autre côté qui est joueur de
l'équipe première bonsoir on va parler
avec vous dans un instant de la suite de
la saison pour vous et à des barrages de
fédéral 2 qui vont s'ouvrir et qui vont
bientôt débuter et on va parler tout de
suite de rugby à 5 on commençait à en
parler tout à l'heure en début
d'émission la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat est l'Île-de-France lance sa
deuxième édition du Trophée mixte de
rugby à 5 autres au total 96 joueurs et
joueurs jouer aux joueurs des apprentis
de 8 centres de formation de la région
vont s'affronter à ce jeudi 20 avril à
Marcoussis au Centre National de Rugby
c'est le la capitale de du rugby en
France avec le CFA de Versailles qui est
notamment de la partie on en parle avec
Mathieu Berrier qui est toujours avec
nous chef de travaux coach de l'équipe
du Centre de formation des apprentis de
Versailles et à vos côtés nous a rejoint
également Brice Hernandez bon vous êtes
vous apprentis donc au CFA de Versailles
et vous faites partie donc de cette
équipe mixte de rugby A5 l'objectif de
ce tournoi Mathieu verrier qui est-il
c'est de promouvoir l'apprentissage
promouvoir la pratique du rugby mixte
aussi l'entraîne en fait on a une
association qui s'est faite avec la
Ligue de rugby et donc en fait depuis la
deuxième c'est la deuxième saison là
qu'on fait et donc pour pouvoir
promouvoir le rugby promouvoir aussi les
jeunes qui puissent aller vers le rugby
parce que c'est quand même un sport qui
est pas forcément qui fait peur
certainement donc le toucher ça permet
d'être attirer beaucoup de jeunes comme
brise par exemple qui vient qui connaît
pas du tout le rugby qui a pris les
règles en deux mois et qui va faire le
tournoi jeudi prochain et encore le
remporter j'espère pour Versailles
confirmer Brice vous connaissez rien du
du rugby à la base non pas du tout alors
qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré juste avant
la pratique du rugby toucher
justement le fait qu'il y ait pas de
placage et que ça soit pas
si je peux dire brut comme le rugby
classique et puis voilà promouvoir aussi
on imagine les valeurs d'un sport qui
est le rugby aussi vous êtes vous-même
pratiquant ou jouer il me semble au
plaisir Rugby Club en plus c'est ça
comme quoi mais c'est quoi les valeurs
du rugby je vais faire réagir mes
invités autour de la table Cyril les
valeurs du rugby
la solidarité à la base je pense que
c'est plus c'est très intéressant sur
les écoles de rugby c'est
l'épanouissement la vie de groupe et
avec un peu de compétition bien sûr mais
c'est quand même ces valeurs là et puis
de solidarité entre eux Bastien le voit
tous les dimanches sur le net sur les
terrains
justement on a vraiment des grosses
valeurs de solidarité et cette année
c'est ça qui nous a amené à avoir de si
bons résultats d'ailleurs mettre en
avant aussi des projets pédagogiques
c'est aussi ça l'objectif aussi la
pédagogie on a le sport déjà aussi au
niveau du CFA parce que en étant
apprenti certains métiers comme la
boulangerie la pâtisserie bon bah
forcément on prend quelques kilos donc
c'est bien aussi que les jeunes fassent
du sport on a des coiffeuses on a des
esthéticiennes qui viennent aussi jouer
avec nous donc franchement c'est tous
les métiers qui peuvent participer tous
les CFA de d'Île-de-France justement
vont pouvoir participer et se rencontrer
ce jour-là ça vous fait quoi brise de
jouer au Centre National de Rugby alors
je disais tout à l'heure la capitale du
rugby c'est là où l'équipe de France de
rugby s'entraîne je vais fâcher nos amis
du Sud-Ouest mais en tout cas c'est un
c'est un centre c'est le Centre national
du rugby ça vous fait quoi de pouvoir
fouler ces pelouse et de jouer pour ce
tournoi là-bas
je sais pas trop j'ai jamais été donc
je serai pas vous répondre pas de souci
mais ça vous tenait à cœur aussi de
pratiquer le rugby dans cette formule 1
un tournoi mixte oui je trouve ça super
que bah il y a des filles qui puissent
jouer avec nous et comme c'est au
toucher bah ça va
des joueurs comme Brice qui ont
découvert le rugby du coup comment vous
les avez entraînés comment ça s'est
passé la préparation c'est eux qui ont
été
moteur en fait on a mis une inscription
tout le monde pouvait s'inscrire ils
sont venus de même il y a pas eu de
force forcer quelqu'un à venir après
première entraînement un peu difficile
ouais forcément on découvre on apprend
des règles on comprend pas forcément
tout mais ça se fait ça s'est très bien
les jeunes filles sont de plus en plus
motivés on a quand même Stéphanie qui
est aussi la deuxième année qui a fait
le tournoi on a un joueur de l'année
dernière qui a joué en équipe dès MAPA
plaisir dans le coup et qui refait le
tournoi cette année en deuxième année en
BTM parce que c'est la deuxième édition
il me semble
la première donc on remet nos petites en
jeu
on va certainement remporter
vous êtes confiant pour ce tournoi
est-ce que le niveau des autres CFA est
bon est-ce que vous savez à peu près le
niveau non ça va être de la découverte
on sait que l'année dernière on était
au-dessus mais maintenant cette année je
pense qu'ils ont vu aussi ils ont appris
des règles ils ont sport aussi nous
malheureusement on fait pas de sport au
CFA avec on a pas de prof de sport en
fait donc c'est nous gratuitement
gracieusement avec amour pour le rugby
quand on participe à ça aussi et il me
semble que on annonce cette journée
enfin en parallèle il y a aussi deux
concours il y a celui du meilleur
maillot le meilleur haka également c'est
ça vous allez travailler aussi là dessus
du coup Brice oui avec une une fille de
ma classe qui participe au rugby on a
fait le maillot de notre équipe et puis
on a aussi a fait je crois que c'est la
semaine dernière on a fait la
vidéo pour le concours du meilleur aka
donc là on est imagine l'idée oui
d'attirer un peu plus les jeunes parce
qu'en plus c'est sur TikTok ce concours
directement alors très concrètement pour
terminer ça va se passer comment la
journée de jeudi quel est le programme
alors je dis c'est arrivé à 9h à
Marcoussis distribution de leur maillots
qu'ils ont pas encore vu donc il va
découvrir le vrai maillot ce coup-ci
qu'ils ont dessiné avec ces cila tous
les toutes les équipes ont changé et
après on commence de 10h à midi poule de
9 toutes les équipes se rencontrentes
donc c'est des matchs de deux fois 6
minutes et ensuite l'après-midi c'est
les phases finales premier contre après
je sais pas exactement comment ça va se
dérouler mais les phases finales
l'après-midi repas tous ensemble le midi
à la cantine de Marcoussis
et la finale le soir avant de partir et
remise des deux tous les
de tous les trophées
c'est une chose quand même Bastien et de
jouer à Marcoussis vous avez déjà vu
cette chanson
j'étais stop sien alors c'est et il y a
10 ans déjà et à l'époque on avait cette
cette chance de pouvoir se faire nos
entraînements de rugby là-bas à
Marcoussis donc on y allait le mardi et
parfois le jeudi et ils nous prêtait
même une salle de cours pour faire la
théorie du rugby donc ouais je connais
bien l'installation incroyable nickel
vous avez peut-être une question
pas spécialement mais
peut-être pour pour ce tournoi là que
vous avez que vous allez faire
tout simplement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez apprendre de ce
tournoi peut-être
je sais pas trop mais j'ai déjà appris
que en fait le rugby c'était pas si
sauvage que ça malgré l'absence de
placard mais non parce que je suis
quelqu'un qui a peur des ballons donc
c'était une chance pour moi de
surmonter mes peurs bon bravo en tout
cas pour pour cette initiative Merci à
VOUS Brice merci Mathieu également bon
tournoi à vous et allez Versailles pour
ce tournoi de rugby à 5 qui va se
dérouler donc ce jeudi du côté de
Marcoussis on va continuer de parler de
rugby puisque je le disais on a une une
tablée de presque plaisirroise on a dit
de Versailles mais on a le Rugby Club de
plaisir le plaisir Rugby Club aussi qui
est avec nous pour parler de la suite de
la saison et oui le club a terminé
troisième du championnat de fédéral 2 et
se dirige du coup vers les barrages qui
seront programmés le 30 avril prochain
l'équipe première jouera contre la Saint
Claude une équipe du comité de
Franche-Comté alors déjà messieurs un
petit bilan de cette saison tirer la
mandé peut-être
convenablement l'un sur les 22 matchs on
a réalisé 16 il y a deux mots qui est
forfait on allait retour mais je veux
dire c'est quand même une très bonne
moyenne
ce qui est intéressant également c'est
que le groupe B les espoirs sont
également qualifiés ils font les 4e donc
je dirais que c'est l'ensemble du groupe
senior il y a pas de
groupe séparés il y a vraiment un groupe
une 70 80 joueurs qui qui tournent avec
l'équipe 3 donc c'est puis l'ambiance
comme disait Bastien c'est la base de
des valeurs du club quoi très belle
saison du coup Bastien qu'est-ce qui a
fait la force du club cette saison à
votre avis alors il y a eu des moments
un petit peu d'entrer sur la saison avec
quelques défaites par-ci par là et
notamment la fin de saison qui voulait
peut-être un petit goût amer peut-être
notamment la défaite à Antony en plus
c'est un match qu'on maîtrisait qu'on
perd à la fin un peu bêtement et
naïvement
qui nous aurait permis d'être deuxième
et non troisième donc d'éviter ce match
de barrage ça aurait été ça aurait été
bien mais bon donc voilà après sur les
points positifs je trouve moi je suis
c’était ma quatrième saison là plaisir
et le groupe a bien progressé vraiment
parce que il y a encore trois ans je
jouais le maintien maintenant on est
troisième donc ça c'est très positif et
la force du groupe c'est que
quand on est positif entre nous sur le
terrain
on se rend compte qu'on est fort et on a
appris confiance en fait cette année je
pense que c'est l'année de la confiance
en nous et ça a permis d'avoir des
résultats
vraiment vraiment bon quoi et petites
frustrations tout de même de pas avoir
terminé dans les deux premiers un peu
quand même parce qu'on a été deuxième
longtemps pendant plusieurs semaines et
cette défaite là nous fait basculer et
là on termine à trois points du deuxième
donc
mais bon le partager sa vie oui
c'est quand même je pense que l'équipe
si elle est motivée elle a on est chez
nous elle sera un jour chez nous donc
confiant pour le barrage
c'est quand même toujours un match
particulier un barrage là c'est sur un
match un match tout est arrivé voilà bon
après si tu passes tu as les 16e
aller-retour et le 8ème aller-retour
donc c'est plus stable quoi c'est vrai
que tu maîtrises ça fait deux matchs
quand même c'est un rendez-vous que les
joueurs aiment bien
les matchs de barrage
connu alors certains ont fait la montée
de Fédérale 3 Fédérale 2 et donc là on
arrive pas d'en parler pour revivre ces
moments-là parce que c'est vraiment très
particulier on est voilà les beaux jours
arrivent on peut on peut envoyer du jeu
comme on dit dans jargon et
c'est surtout une atmosphère et une
ambiance vraiment à part et ouais il y a
plus d'adrénaline parce qu'il y a plus
de pression on n'a pas le droit de
perdre et le niveau aussi s'élève là on
va jouer un club qu'on connaît pas du
Jura on sait que ça va être rugueux et
voilà c'est ça ça nous oblige à nous
mettre à niveau est-ce que l'objectif
avant juste d'aborder ce barrage c'est
phases finales c'est clairement la
montée sera un échec à la fin de la
saison s'il n'y a pas de montée tirer
l'a demandé pour moi pas d'échec non je
dirais que c'est la qualité de la saison
et puis la progression
après c'est du rugby c'est pas une
entreprise donc c'est pas écrit
tout un tas de facteurs qui peut jouer
mais je pense que on met le maximum de
choses de notre côté je veux dire les
structures du club sont aussi
importantes municipalité nous soutient
bien donc on a quand même un bel outil
quoi quelque part et puis bon c'est des
produits locaux quoi c'est bastien un
peu moins mais
voilà donc je dirais que les sur nos
valeurs et sur des intégrations de
jeunes et Mathieu qui était aussi
éducateur sur l'école de rugby vaut
mieux c'est la progression de ces jeunes
sont passés par les cas des juniors et
qui arrivent enseignants
juste Mathieu qui est entré en CFA de
Versailles mais aussi jouer du plaisir
Rugby Club membre c'était pas du tout
prévu à la base c'était pas du tout
voulu de vous réunir mais des fois le
hasard fait bien fait bien les choses
vous portez quel regard vous sur la
saison du plaisir Rugby Club très très
belle saison justement c'est vrai que le
match comme disait
que Anthony ouais ce petit match a fait
perdre la deuxième place mais après
est-ce que vraiment
ça va changer quelque chose le but
maintenant c'est tout gêné c'est tout
phase final c'est vrai que c'est super
bien j'ai eu la chance d'en faire
quelques-unes c'est vrai que c'est
un beau souvenir c'est de la donaldine
vraiment c'est le plus fort encore
justement vous avez l'expérience quelles
sont les conseils que vous donneriez
aujourd'hui de plaisir faut pas se
prendre la tête en fait faut jouer sur
ce qu'on sait jouer c'est je pense
qu'ils ont les cas ici bonne qualité ils
ont des capacités qui sont largement
bonnes il y a une bonne ambiance on le
sent aussi nous à l'équipe 3 quand on va
aller voir jouer on sent que c'est sympa
entre eux je pense qu'ils ont tout pour
tout pour réussir et je précise que vous
affronter un club qui était moins bien
classé que vous sur la saison c'est un
avantage aussi
pour ça que là on joue un sixième on a
fini 3e donc voilà c'est pas le même
rugby donc voilà comment on sait pas
réagir
selon les régions aussi
on a des moyens on vous souhaite la
monter pour la fin de saison en tout cas
c'est pas un maximum de plaisir sur sur
ces phase finale Thierry bien sûr
merci à tous les quatre d'être passés en
plateau pour parler de rugby sur le
rendez-vous de plaisir au précise le
barrage ce sera le 30 avril prochain
contre Saint-Claude à domicile l'appel à
lancer c'est un maximum de spectateurs
dans les tribunes on imagine pour vous
soutenir sur sur ce match des barrages
et on va passer maintenant nickel aux
autres résultats sportifs du week-end
dans les Yvelines et il y avait
notamment du football le FC Versailles
respire un peu dans le championnat de
National après quatre matchs sans
victoire les hommes de Chris se sont
imposés un à zéro ce week-end face au
Football Club Villefranche Beaujolais le
but a été marqué à la 79e minute par mon
diprunier avec cette victoire les
joueurs de la cité royale reste en
embuscade pour monter en fin de saison
les Marseillais sont quatrième avec 48
points à quatre points de la première
place du championnat national 2 deuxième
défaite consécutive pour Poissy les
pistes à quai se sont lourdement
inclinés ce week-end sur sur le terrain
de Chambly le score est sans appel 3-0
les yvelin ont pris deux buts en
première période et ils ont marqué
contre leur camp secondaire au
classement Poissy est toujours 5e de ce
championnat de National de chiens du
basket à présent Montigny handball
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux emporté une
belle victoire sur son terrain
contrebervilliers ce samedi soir les ini
Montaigne l'emportent 27 à 21 avec
notamment 9 réalisations de maillis
est-il au pays et quatre buts de nid en
push la SMV se retrouve à la cinquième
place du championnat à trois journées de
la fin et peut toujours espérer un
podium en fin de saison du football
américain non c'était une blague on va
parler de karting à présent karting
alors une belle performance pour Arthur
laurier le jeune pilote de 13 ans
originaire de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
c'est classé troisième de la première
manche du championnat d'Europe junior de
karting électrique à jenk a Genk en
Belgique Arthur Lorimier qui espère
faire un jour carrière dans les plus
grandes catégories de sport automobile
et pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
les plaisirsois peuvent laisser éclater
leur joie les filles du CTC trap plaisir
Sky viennent de battre l'équipe des
Mureaux lors de la dernière journée du
championnat une victoire synonyme de
monter en régionale ce match les
joueuses l'ont maîtrisé de bout en bout
en étant largement devant des lapauses
le score 35 à 16 quand tu joues un match
pour le titre et que tu joues à domicile
avec ton public bien sûr ça pousse
davantage il faut aussi féliciter cette
équipe des Mureaux qui reste une bonne
équipe ce dimanche 16 avril rien ne
semblait pouvoir perturber les joueuses
locales au retour des vestiaires les
plaisirsoisses continuent à dérouler
l'emporte logiquement 69 à 35
donc c'est ça le mot du match ensemble
c'est au titre de notre saison à l'image
de notre saison on a fait ce qu'on
savait faire on s'est donné c'était un
match plaisir mais c'est jamais facile
on est resté dedans c'est pas facile
d'être concentré tout le match on a
réussi à le faire avec cette victoire
trap plaisir Sky termine premier devant
l'équipe de Montigny-le-Bretonneux avec
un bilan de 16 victoires et de défaites
l'équipe commence déjà à se projeter sur
la saison prochaine il va falloir
reconstruire encore une fois parce qu'on
va monter de division donc forcément
c'est un niveau qui est supérieur ça va
demander beaucoup d'engagement beaucoup
de stratégies beaucoup de cohésion en
attendant de reconstruire les joueuses
veulent savourer une montée déjà
historique
[Applaudissements]
on va maintenant parler baseball et plus
précisément des Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les inondins ou
de grandes ambitions en cette nouvelle
saison alors pour nous parler de cette
saison en cours nous avons été rejoint
par deux invités en plateau sur la
droite il y a José des Araujo bonsoir
manager de l'équipe première et Dylan
Mayeux bonsoir
non vous êtes le président et vous le
manager de l'équipe première pardon
j'avais inversé les les catégories alors
on va parler tout d'abord l'actualité
vous avez joué ce weekend contre
Toulouse et vous avez perdu les deux
matchs ce qu'on peut revenir déjà sur
cette rencontre Dylan
on a eu un petit un petit manque de
chance ce week-end on est passé à
travers on sait pas trop sur quoi
remettre les défaites parce que on a été
assez opportuniste quand même mais
ça va pas suffi pour pour ramener au
moins une victoire comment vous
expliquer cette double défaite
donc du coup
on est rentré hier soir tard dans la
nuit parce que on fait les déplacements
en minibus donc Toulouse c'est un peu
loin donc ouais bah le premier match on
était plutôt dans les clous jusqu'à un
petit point de bascule bon ou Toulouse
prend l'avantage on n'arrive pas à
rattraper et sur le deuxième match
pareil ça se tient jusqu'au 5e 6e manche
on est à zéro ils sont devant mais bon
et après on bascule et c'est toujours
quand on est en retard sur compliqué de
faire les efforts et quand on commence à
faire les efforts après bon voilà il y a
une période relâche puis voilà on prend
on va faire les deux matchs alors qu'on
voulait les gagner bon voilà c'est c'est
un petit hic dans notre parcours mais
bon lâche rien on nous on a notre
objectif qui sont les play-off donc on
va y aller nickel justement dans minibus
l'ambiance était comment on va dire
qu'elle allait on était
digestif à tous c'était bon c'était
plutôt bien après après les deux
défaites moi c'est toujours dur à
encaisser c'est sûr mais ça ça enlève
pas la bonne humeur de l'équipe et on a
pu tous se faire un petit retour tous
ensemble sur le sur le retour du coup
alors vous avez actuellement un bilan de
3 victoires pour 3 défaites votre
sentiment président sur ce début de
saison bah c'est un bon
débute par rapport aux résultats de ce
weekend mais sinon c'est un bon début de
saison parce qu'on démarre assez fort
parce qu'on va accrocher le champion de
France chez eux on leur prend un match
ou quoi et sur le deuxième voilà c'est
comme l'année dernière on est un petit
peu en dessous mais voilà on sait qu'on
peut les prendre d'ailleurs c'est eux
qu'on rencontre dans quel jour ici donc
non vraiment on est je dirais sur nos
toujours sur notre objectif on a des
petites choses à régler en effet parce
que Toulouse on aurait dû prendre les
deux matchs même si voilà on est sur
cette année sur un championnat avec deux
groupes de 5 sur des équipes qui sont
renforcées beaucoup parce que on va
passer à un groupe de 8 donc il y a deux
équipes qui qui tombent donc tout le
monde veut rester et donc voilà c'est on
sait que tous les matchs vont être
compliqués mais on sait qu'on a on a la
possibilité au fait d'aller gagner ces
matchs là multiple champion de France
vous avez aussi l'impression qu'ils sont
jouables cette saison et compte déjà
trois défaites il y a un coup à jouer
face à autant il y a quelques années je
dirais entre voilà il y a 5 10 ans
c'était
intouchables et au fur et à mesure des
années on voit que on peut prendre des
matchs on peut faire des longs matchs
contre eux et bon au final après le le
résultat de fin de saison ils sont
toujours très performants mais on sent
que pendant la saison on est capable de
les accrocher clairement l'équipe vise
la victoire finale cette saison on
cherche on cherche concrètement aller au
player cette année champion peut-être
c'est possible éventuellement
éventuellement je pense qu'on a les
ressources pour pour aller jusqu'au bout
Président c'est un objectif qu'on fixé
vous en tant que président aux joueurs
ou vous allez affiner un petit peu au
fur et à mesure de la saison les
playoffs c'est parce que ça fait déjà
deux ans qu'on passe aux portes genre de
très très peu donc du coup on veut y
aller et après l'objectif c'est shop sur
le compte France aussi champion sur le
Challenge de France qui se joue parce
que nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est aller
repartir faire des coupes d'Europe comme
on l'a déjà fait en 2019 c'était une
expérience incroyable avec un groupe et
une semaine de baseball donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on souhaite
revivre avec le groupe donc c'est ça
notre objectif et pour y arriver c'est
les play-offs essentiellement et puis
aussi bon le chavage de France on veut
aussi faire un résultat Dylan parler des
arguments qu'à l'équipe cette année
c'est quoi ces arguments quels sont les
forces bah on a toujours je dirais nos
lanceurs phares York qui est toujours
avec nous et en Franck Lopez Robinson
Maestre qui est revenu aussi donc on a
ces joueurs qui sont avec nous et puis
sur les qui s'inscrivent dans un dans un
parcours personnel on les aide aussi
Gabriel du Carmaux notre catcheur qui
revient on a récupéré un un short stop
donc un haricot qui vient d'Espagne
aussi donc on on a des gens qui sont
intéressés et puis après nous on a notre
vivier et on a des jeunes qui jouent
avec toujours la volonté
déjà des perspectives à nos jeunes pour
qu'ils puissent rester ici de se
développer et venir jouer avec l'équipe
première là cette année on en a trois on
espère en intégré encore plus l'année
prochaine donc voilà c'est vraiment
c'est ça c'est une force vive on a un
petit peu l'impression que les joueurs
étrangers tombent amoureux du club de
montcy-le-bretonneux comment vous
l'expliquer Dylan
j'ai pas vraiment d'explication c'est
juste qu'on arrive à je sais pas on a
une ambiance de famille dans dans
l'équipe et on a beaucoup de joueurs qui
leur ressemblent même de l'extérieur des
équipes qu'on affronte qui
qui voit que bah je sais pas on est
vraiment comme une famille on est tous
ensemble on est dans des bons des bons
délires j'ai envie de dire
j'ai pas vraiment explications à ça
c'est juste que il y a un bon noyau et
tout le monde tout le monde prend quand
il vient à Montigny prochain match ce
sera contre Rouen le 30 avril c'est déjà
un tournant on peut le dire dans la
saison ah oui peut-être un petit peu
trop tôt non non non non c'est des c'est
un objectif c'est à dire on sait il
vient chez nous en plus c'est une
journée un peu spéciale puisqu'on a des
cérémonies prévues au nom d'amis donc on
a enfin c'est vraiment ça va être une
journée importante en plus c'est notre
premier match à domicile donc on est à
la maison donc on a vraiment à cœur de
faire un résultat ce jour-là anti mot
sur la nicoton justement présidente
ancienne présidente du club des cougars
antimote décédé en fin d'année dernière
ouais c'est donc voilà Annie une grosse
figure du club qui a été président
pendant longtemps avec une famille qui
est très très liée au club donc je lui
dis encore vice-présidente avec nous
donc ouais on a décidé elle est décédée
l'année dernière donc c'était enfin
c'était assez dur pour tout le monde et
voilà on va faire une cérémonie de 30 à
son hommage donc il y aura une plaque
déposée dans les tribunes et le terrain
va être baptisé en ce moment voilà donc
on tient aussi remercier la mairie de
Montigny qui a accepté cette demande
qu'on a fait une grosse journée en
prévision le 30 avril pour pour la
mémoire et également avec ce match on
disait peut-être tournant de la saison
face à Rouen le 30 avril prochain
réception de Rouen on le rappelle merci
à tous les deux d'être venu parler de ce
début de saison en plateau je rappelle
Dylan Mayeux manager de l'équipe
première voilà cette fois-ci je vais pas
me tromper et José de Araujo président
des Kuga de Montigny le Bretonneux
Michael je suis un petit peu difficile
avec vous ce soir on avait prévu de
parler de course à pied juste avant les
coureurs mais c'est pas grave on va
parler quand même de course à pied à
présent avec un événement qui était au
programme ce weekend dans les Yvelines
il y a pas de souci j'aime bien les
pièges aujourd'hui je vous en veux
aujourd'hui il y a pas de souci la 11e
édition de la Piscia case était
organisée ce dimanche dans le domaine
forestier de Poissy plusieurs cours
c'était au programme du
la course phare de la journée sur cette
distance c'est Sandra Daudet Dorian
konyx tous deux pensionnaires de Poissy
à triathlon qui a remporté la victoire
on écoute la réaction du sportif de
l'équipe de France au micro de tv78 j'ai
un tous les ans depuis 8 ou 9 ans
maintenant et ouais c'est toujours une
course dure parce que il y a de la route
il y a des chemins ça monte ça descend
il y a plein de relance donc c'est
toujours très sympa puis un bon niveau
on s'est éclaté c'est arrivé proche ça
s'est joué jusqu'à la fin donc ça on a
dû vraiment l'épuiser pour j'ai dû
vraiment puiser pour battre Aurélien
au total ils étaient plus de 850
coureurs inscrits au départ de la course
du 10 km merci Michael pour ces
actualités sportives c'est bientôt la
fin de ce 7 8 mais avant de vous laisser
on va jeter un dernier coup d'oeil aux
prévisions météo de demain
et une belle journée au programme de
votre journée de mardi éclaircies au
grand soleil dans la matinée selon où
vous vous trouvez dans les Yvelines il
faudra compter 8 degrés dans les
secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles et Houdan dans l'après-midi
le ciel se voilera par endroits mais ça
devrait rester agréable côté température
compter 14 degrés à Versailles et Houdan
15 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Rambouillet petite précision avant de
vous laisser nous avions recevoir
Babette de Rosières dans cette édition
auteur de la face cachée de la politique
en Île-de-France bavette de Rosières
chef de cuisine dans les Yvelines
également à femme engagée en politique
dans ce livre elle dépend la politique
entre clientélisme méthode de gestion et
promesse non tenue finalement n'a pas pu
se rendre à temps sur ce plateau nous
l'a réinviterons bien sûr à une autre
occasion pour parler de ce livre qui est
apparaître aux éditions orphi ce sera le
27 avril prochain voilà c'est la fin de
ce 7 8 merci de nous avoir suivis on se
retrouve dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]